l'espoir du wakeboard français est
ivelinois Tibo Lagel a seulement 16 ans
et se lance dans le sport de glisse il y
a 2 ans ce sportif originaire de Vau sur
scène a découvert cette discipline à
l'âge de 14 ans c'est grâce à son père
que va naître cette passion c'est grâce
à lui que j'ai ce bateau pour
m'entraîner il me suit partout il
m'accompagne par exemple au championnat
du monde cette année au Portugal il a
tout organisé il s'occupe un peu de tout
quoi depuis sa progression est
fulgurante son palmarès grandit d'année
en année en seulement 2 ans il gagne le
championnat de France deux fois d'affilé
il y a 3 ans je me disais pas champion
de France et encore moins une 2uxè année
de plus participeré au championnat du
monde participer au championnat d'Europe
avec l'équipe de France ça fait beaucoup
de choses en si peu de temps grâce à ces
titres la Fédération Française de wgbard
le sélectionne en équipe de France une
nouvelle marche franchie dans sa
carrière j'étais très content euh je m'y
attendais pas forcément je vais tout
faire pour pour montrer queils m'ont pas
sélectionné pour rien même si sa
carrière semble toute tracée livelin
reste prudent il se laisse 2 ans pour
évoluer après son bac en poche
l'objectif sera de rejoindre la ville
d'Orlando en Floride pour continuer son
apprentissage et pourquoi pas tenter une
carrière professionnelle et accomplir
ses plus grands rêv c'est participer au
prob tour en Floride et au double up au
double up Red Bull Parks ça peut être
possible en fonction de mes de années de
progression d'ici làib va participer à
plusieurs il disputera le 30 octobre
prochain jusqu'au 5 novembre les
championnats d'Europe de wbard en
[Musique]
Sicile